if we die tonight mankind dies with us
I'm fanboying a little bit here and
those of you who know me know that I
don't do that I caught on to all the
little fun and nods that are in Genesis
I'm going to tell you all about it I'm
Gabe hole writer this is hashtag news
now Terminator Genisys kind of screws
with the entire Terminator narrative we
made an entire video of just talking
about the timelines go check that out
when you're done watching me talk to you
about Easter eggs let's get into it
early in Genesis there's a shot-for-shot
remake of a portion of the original
terminator here's some of the specific
things you see repeated in this part
naked Arnold arriving the trash guy a
shot overlooking Los Angeles the entire
Kyle Reese arrival section including how
he steals some homeless guys pants
there's that cop that starts chasing him
only now it's a t-1000 wait how can they
change time like that more on that in
the timeline video Kyle Reese in the
t1000 repeat the whole department store
chase sequence including the shameless
nod to Nike shoes why do they remake it
all instead of just using the original
footage another company owns the rights
to it and he couldn't get them sorry
they had to make some slight tweaks
though because of the lower film rating
they had to cut out Arnold's a member
they also couldn't get back bill paxton
who was the leader of this group
DeGeneres yeah this guy's a goggle kid
sure it was six back while the t1000 is
new to 1984 we can tell if the exact
same model only Asian which is cool then
facial performance same head bobbing
through a broken window same running
same sword arms even Arnold gets to play
with those sword arms
hello sarih karna fun fact the producers
actually went back to Robert Patrick the
one who played the original t1000 and
asked him if you'd like to reprise his
role to which he responded no I'm old
now I don't run anymore I have a bad hip
and so they offered him a cameo as an
old man forgets to sit in a comfy chair
nice going Robert I'll be back Sarah
Connor gives us the classic line tell me
if you want to live not as epic as when
Arnold says it come with me if you want
to live way better than calories from
the original come with me if you want to
live right after that line Sarah Connor
says she plays a lot better now that
she's a badass way more than in the
first one when she's a waitress
pretending to be tough in Genesis before
Kyle Reese is sent back he's giving the
exact same cheesy message from John
Connor that he gave to Sarah in the
original Terminator I must survive where
I will never exist it's very
heartwarming thank you Sarah for your
courage through the dark years and
cheesy
Kyle Reese's ominous description of
terminators and how they operate in the
first one repeated now by John Connor
about himself as a new form of
Terminator it can't be bargained with I
can't be reasoned with
it doesn't feel pity or remorse or fear
pretty awesome just like in the past
terminators where he's quick to point
out the terminators always eager to
point out when he hasn't killed someone
oh oh great that's just great
I did not kill him and of course we have
the mandatory classic I'll be back which
is probably the simplest string of words
to ever become super epic the Judgment
Day that we all know and love those same
images come up in Terminator Genisys May
9th 1997 Skynet woke up
also that's Kyle Reese taking on the
same kind of narration that Sarah Connor
did in Terminator 2 three billion human
lives ended on August 29 narration
bringing overly complicated storylines
down to our level Sarah Connor picture
that Kyle Reese has from the original
Terminator same picture hotter actress
swapped in she's hotter drip way to make
a dragon want to retire Sarah Connor is
once again curious about what
time-travel feels like oh it's it like
you go through time and this time she
gets to experience that pain firsthand
by traveling forward in time young Kyle
Reese working on a funky little dirt
bike just like his son John Connor
ah they both like to work on machines
wait that must mean oh oh no no
nevermind thought I had something also
in this version John's little ginger
friend bud Nick is replaced with a dog
also in a reference to Terminator
Salvation Kyle Reese ends up blowing all
the CGI skin off of a terminator
references the production being done
with paying for a CGI Arnold from 1984
also we see some more Terminator
positivity with the classic thumbs up
that we know from Terminator 2 as he
goes into a lava pit or maybe he means a
thumbs up in a kind of Middle Eastern
sense where it's like right up your you
know this would make sense because the
Terminator is kind of a rude guy I'm
gonna kill that guy cause I'm a
terminator also the moment where he says
bite me
probably reference to the original
terminators fua whole moment which pg-13
can't really come close to [ __ ] you
[ __ ] in Genesis a t800 is sent back
to 1973 in a flashback where we see that
it once again found an entire leather
outfit to put on boy these things have
something for leather I wonder what else
they like moving on she recognized this
boombox yeah this is a double Easter Egg
because not only does John Connor use it
in Terminator Salvation where he plays
guns and roses just like he did in
Terminator 2
but in Genesis Sarah Connor listens to I
want to be sedated on this boombox which
is what John Connor was supposed to be
listening to in the script for
Terminator 2 making a little Easter egg
omelet and they squeeze in one more
sarah blasts the music so loud she
misses a tender moment between a
terminator and her future boyfriend
while in the first one sarah's roommates
music also keeps her from catching a
tender moment between her boyfriend and
a terminator the Terminator killing him
it's like the guys in Terminator 2 John
Connor tries to teach the Terminator how
to smile it's clear in Genesis that
Sarah Connor has also repeated these
steps to teaching the Terminator how to
smile and I think he nails it kind of in
a fight the t800 once again loses an arm
which is starting to seem like a
weakness of design and once again it's
left unaccounted for now then the first
one this arm went on to build what we
would know to become Skynet we'll just
have to wait and see what happens with
this missing arm member miles Dyson from
t2 guy who blew himself up with
Cyberdyne ha ha kick he's back is
somehow in 2017 look that's him yeah and
his son has taken over the family
business
it's good that they've kept it in the
family another almost completely redone
scene of when they're driving away from
the menacing t1000 running at them in
the car and they're like I'm how we look
I'm you to another clip cheese you get
the idea they smash right into a
DeLorean
a fun nod to a time travel series that
also went back to the original and
changed a few things very cool scene in
Genesis here where John Connor is being
pulled apart by a giant magnet tons of
little references in here but my
favorite thing is that it looks like the
evolution of man with John Connor as the
man robot hybrid as the most of all
section of the whole thing very cool the
post-credits scene isn't so much of a
reference but it's definitely something
you might have missed because they've
never had one of these in a Terminator
movie before nothing too crazy just kind
of like that old-school 80s action movie
thing where the villain always reopens
his eyes meaning it's gonna come back in
the sequel but that guy is Skynet slash
Doctor Who oh yeah that's another thing
you might have miss Matt Smith the
former Whovian doctor plays Skynet which
is now some kind of humanoid robot thing
I don't know
also another bit of casting trivia for
you Emilia Clarke who plays Sarah Connor
is famous for being the mother of
dragons and Eris on Game of Thrones
where she co-stars with Lina heed Lee
aka Cersei who plays Sarah Connor in the
Terminator TV show now they have another
reason to hate each other
catfight catfight no 2015 yep can't do
this nope not good
and in this deleted scene Arnold totally
needs my help and is actually a big
personal fan of my chin Arnold come
immediately you must join the fight for
the future well I have you on TV do you
think you could plug gates channel
Gabe's channel 6's is not one of my
visions parameters he didn't seem to be
a fan of your channel no no he is he is
he's just he's very focused if you are
still confused about the weird new
terminator timeline check out that video
here subscribe if you enjoyed this movie
a trivia as much as I did of course I
did I got to give it to you not like
that hey please leave a comment if you
think I missed any fun facts or if you
think I got anything wrong hey I've been
Gabe Hill writer and if all it takes to
travel through time is to strip down
naked in public well I'm gonna go watch
myself be born
whoa